histidines feed my cancer. Most of my protein has been plant-based and are high in histidines.
Meat is an option, but I've read a number of times that animal protein can feed cancer.
What do you recommend? Well, it's true. amino acids can feed cancer. The most common amino acid that
is a cancer feeder, you could say it glutamate, and that's the thing that you need to stay away from
number one. The most common source of fuel for any cancer is going to be glucose, though.
By far, it's going to be glucose. So stay on a diet that's relatively low in glucose. What are you
eating? Well, you're eating vegetables. Well, a lot of vegetables will break down into glucose
will protein break down into glucose. No, protein is going to break down into amino acids,
but can my cancer change its fuel source and feed off amino acids? Yes, but by far in general,
you're going to have a cancer that's going to be more glucose dependent. So stay in a low glucose
diet is going to mean that you're going to be eating more animal proteins. So,
again, I'm, you know, in the camp, I think testing it, retesting to see where the fuel source is,
is the best way to go. Second best way to go would be to do experimentation with yourself.
As my cancer stayed at bay with my diet, then maybe stay on that diet. If my cancer stayed at bay
with my diet for a period of time, and now my cancer is starting to grow, then it's time to change
things up and to change your diet. So if I have been eating like a type of ketogenic diet,
or ketogenic like what I've stayed really low on sugar, and I've eaten a lot more animal proteins,
and then my cancer starts to grow again, maybe the fuel source has changed and you need to switch
to maybe a raw more vegetarian type diet for a period of time. So you have to be able to, to make
changes. Cancer is trying to find a fuel source at all times you have to be willing to make changes.
Yes, if histamines are a feeder of your diet, you have to be careful of histamines. But the truth is,
if you look up a histamine diet online, pretty much everything contains histamine. So you would not
be able to eat really anything. So the idea is not to try to eliminate histamines, which is just
pretty much an impossibility. It's trying to reduce main histamine load. So even, okay,
nuts contain histamines, you're not eating any nuts. Well, maybe you won't eat a bowl full of nuts,
but you can still put some nuts on your salad. So it's a matter of just having balance,
you're not getting these histamines spikes. The other thing you do is histamines in your diet,
obviously are going in your stomach, going into your intestines, and they're broken down by an enzyme
called DAO enzyme. If you add that enzyme to your dietary protocol,
meaning you take the capsule of DAO when you eat food, when you eat a meal,
you will help break down those histamines, and then you won't have that issue with histamines.
Histamines can also be an issue, can get more complicated histamines, can also be an issue,
if the person has a lot of leaky gut issues and a lot of inflammation from something totally other
than histamine. Let's say they have a undiagnosed client sensitivity. So they have antibodies to
gluten. They're still eating gluten on their diet. It's causing this inflammation of the gut,
so you're causing this inflammatory reaction that got increased production of histamine,
and then you're absorbing those, and that's causing systemic inflammation, and that's the problem.
So looking for sources of systemic inflammation is the next step to go as well. So I recommend,
that's why with all of our cancer patients, we give them access to our autoimmune course. Why?
I don't have autoimmune disease. Well, having a co-orbidity of an autoimmune disorder with cancer can be
a co-feeder of the cancer, and a co-inhibitor of a person being able to get rid of the cancer,
because they're also, they're dealing with these battles at multiple fronts. So if you can
defeat the battles at the different fronts, decreasing the inflammation at different areas, you can,
your immune system is going to be calm down enough to be able to concentrate on killing the cancer.
Then with diet, again, with cancer, you do have to get enough protein in your diet in order to
make the T cells and natural killer cells that are so necessary, those are the some type of lymphocytes
that are really going to be cancer killers, and they are completely dependent on protein intakes.
You have to be able to eat enough protein in order to get that. So it's a little tricky to maneuver,
but you have to work through those circumstances.